-Our next guest is
a very funny actor and comedian
you know from his work on
"Saturday Night Live."
He stars in "Mr. Mayor,"
which airs Tuesday nights
at 8:30 here on NBC.
Let's take a look.
-Sir, I need your advice.
-Jayden...
-My friend works at
the discotheque,
but he just got invited to play
at the Olympics.
But the owner of
the discotheque is his husband,
and he's going to be
so mad at --
-Jayden. Jayden!
I'm on live TV right --
[ Chuckling ] Right now.
-Oh [bleep]
Did I say [bleep]
-No, no.
-I'm [bleep] sorry.
I'm sorry!
[Bleep] [Bleep]
[Bleep] [bleep] your [bleep]
I'm sorry!
-Now get out.
-[Bleep]
[ Door closes ]
-Oh, boy.
Where was I?
Um, I don't recall.
And neither should you,
Los Angeles.
-Please welcome back to the show
our very good friend
Bobby Moynihan!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back, my friend.
-Hello! It's so good to see you.
-It's so nice to have you back
in New York City for a few days.
-Yes, it's wonderful.
-Are you enjoying being back out
here on the East Coast?
-It's weird to be back.
I haven't been back in
like two years.
-That's nuts.
-Very different.
-Yeah.
-A lot's different.
You've got --
Your daughter is 4.
-Is she?
-Yeah.
We did some --
We checked Wikipedia, yeah.
-I got to check in with her.
Yeah, yeah.
I hope she's doing well.
No.
Yeah, no, she's 4.
She's the best.
-What's she into?
-Everything that I am.
-Alright.
I mean, you have --
I will say this.
I say this lovingly.
I feel like you have
a lot of tastes
you were just waiting for a
child to share with you.
-Correct. I realize what
I'm best at is
playing with the toys.
Yeah, a lot of trolls right now.
A lot -- She, like,
had a little spooky phase.
-Okay.
-A lot of monsters like Dracula.
-Oh, that's fun to be
inside of that.
-Yeah. What every little girl
loves -- mummies.
She's the best.
-That's really exciting.
And the
birthday's coming up, right?
-Yes. Once a year.
-Is that what they're doing now?
Wow. Kids.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Does she, like,
have any theme requests
for her birthday or is...
-Every year,
she asks for a theme request,
and every year, it ends up being
"Toy Story" somehow.
I don't know why or how,
but it does.
Maybe because
we don't buy new decorations.
No, yeah, I think this year,
it's probably going --
Right now,
very heavy into Sonic.
Sonic and Knuckles right now.
-Oh, okay. Alright.
Oh, that's exciting.
-Yeah, it'll change
in like 14 hours.
-You have a fantastic cast.
We saw Ted Danson in the clip.
Holly Hunter, as well.
A couple of legends.
-Yes. Yeah.
-What are they like
to work with?
-The best.
I've learned so much about
acting from watching
Holly Hunter for 40 seconds,
and from Ted Danson,
I learned that you should have
turkey and apples
like every hour.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-'Cause he looks outstanding.
He looks really good.
-Yeah, he's a
really healthy man.
-Yeah. And it's just
turkey and apples on the hour?
-It's just 7 feet
filled with turkey and apples.
-You got to eat a lot of turkey.
Yeah, you don't want to go
higher than the -- Yeah.
-You can't, you can't.
It'll come out the top.
-You do -- I know you're doing
a lot of V.O. stuff,
and during the pandemic,
people who were smart
built sort of
makeshift home studios.
Did you do that?
-Yes, almost instantly.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
The first V.O. job I got,
I said, "Can I keep this?
Can I pay you
to keep all of this stuff?"
-Because they sent you the gear.
-Because they sent,
like, a setup
and they said "yes," and I did.
And I haven't -- I've been in
my closet for two years
doing voices, like every other
45-year-old man.
-You come out to play trolls
and then you go back in.
-I play and then I go play
in the closet.
Yeah, yeah.
-You have a show you're doing
a voice on, "Lightning Wolves."
-Yes. Yes.
-So, explain "Lightning Wolves"
real quick.
-"Lightning Wolves"
is a cartoon,
a bunch of shorts that I wrote.
It's based on --
loosely based on those, like,
'80s cartoons --
"ThunderCats," "He-Man,"
"Voltron," "G.I. Joe."
And -- But this version is --
You know, it was all about
teaching people life lessons
or teaching
children life lessons,
but it was really just there
to sell them toys.
-Yeah.
-And that's what this is.
It's just a bunch of
'80s characters realizing
that they mean nothing
and they're just toys.
-You also -- Welcome to
the children's-book-author game.
-Yes, congratulations.
-Thank you very much, yeah.
It's fun to write a kid's book.
-I just read your
children's book
to my daughter
and her whole class.
-How'd it go?
-Not great.
No, I'm just kidding!
They didn't get it.
They were sad after I read it.
-Oh, no!
That doesn't -- That's not good.
-Two of the kids said, "I don't
want to do school anymore."
-What?!
It made him stop wanting --
-Yeah.
One said, "What's a bear?"
-What's a bear?
Well, they should probably go
back to school.
-That kid's not great.
-Should probably do
double school.
-No, it went great.
I did your voice.
-Oh, good.
-It was great. It was fun.
It's so crazy.
You will read my book
to my daughter's class soon.
-Yes. And your book is called?
-"Not All Sheep Are Boring!"
-That's great.
Is that the take, that a lot of
kids think sheep are boring?
-Yeah. It's about a little toad
who says, you know,
"People count sheep
to fall asleep,
but not all sheep are boring.
I can prove it."
And, by the end,
you realize he's wrong.
All sheep are boring.
-And then -- and then the
butcher comes?
-And then -- Yeah.
Kids need to learn.
-Hey, so, you -- You've --
Again, I've known you
to do animated voices
for a long time.
You did one in our show,
"The Awesomes."
-Yeah, I was
Teleportation Larry.
-Yeah, a very famous,
a very important character
to the canon.
You also played a --
The Penguin in
"Batman: The Audio Adventures."
-Yeah, our
friend Dennis McNicholas.
-Yep. I did a little voice work
in this, as well.
The Penguin, though,
I couldn't help but notice,
does feel to, like,
sort of complete the circle,
because you played Danny DeVito
on the show a couple times.
-Correct, yes.
I was lucky enough when they let
me to play Danny DeVito.
-Here's you and Taran as
George Clooney and Danny DeVito.
-Aww, my Taran.
-Yeah.
Were you -- Are you pointing
'cause you were worried --
-I just like tickling
this little guy.
-I thought you were like that,
"Now, this one's me."
-No, I just saw it and went,
"He's adorable!"
-You also -- This
was "'Star Wars' Auditions,"
and this was Danny DeVito
auditioning to play BB-8.
-Yeah, that was all Colin Jost.
Colin Jost was like,
"Would you mind dressing up as
Danny DeVito
and just rolling around?"
And I was like, "Yes."
I go, "Should I say anything?"
And he goes, "When you're done,
just go, 'Right?'"
-Perfect.
-That was all Jost.
-And then you were lucky enough
to meet the legend,
Mr. Danny DeVito.
-Yeah. Right after I
played him on the show --
I don't remember if it was
the "Star Wars" one
or the Nespresso one,
but that night, like,
directly after the show,
I had two of my buddies,
Mike and Rob,
from high school, like, with me.
Like, I had two buddies
from high school with me,
because you want to look cool.
And I get them to the party
and we pull up to the party,
and it's the coolest.
And you're on "SNL,"
and your buddies
from high school are there.
And I walk past a car
and I get, like, yanked like --
And I'm like,
"I'm being assaulted,"
and it's Danny DeVito.
He's like, "You think it's funny
playing me?!"
And he immediately let go
and was like, "I love you, kid."
And I was like, "Well,
that was the greatest mo--
I just got attacked by
Danny DeVito
in front of my
high-school buddies."
-I mean,
that's really the dream.
-I've made it.
-So, I was recently --
I was a guest on
"The Tonight Show
with Jimmy Fallon" recently,
and we were
talking about bombing.
-Yeah.
-Especially specifically
bombing at charity gigs.
-Yes.
-And I was talking -- And I
think you know where I'm going.
-Yeah. Oh, no, I saw this. Yeah.
-You and I together bombed worse
than I've ever bombed
in my life.
-It was...the worst.
-Yeah.
-It was the absolute worst.
-It was at
Madison Square Garden.
-Madison Square Garden,
the 12-12-12 Sandy concert,
benefit concert.
-Yeah.
-It had been going on for hours
at this point?
-It was an incredible list
of bands and musicians.
-Like a seven-hour concert,
I think.
And we went on like
hour 5 1/2, 6?
-Yep.
-You recounted it wrong.
We went on after Kanye West...
-Okay.
-...who was
in a kilt and screaming.
-Yeah.
-And then threw his mic
into the audience.
And then when --
And then Chris Rock went,
"Are you going out there?"
-Yeah.
-And I was like, "Yeah."
He's like, "In that costume?"
-Now, we should note that
Bobby and I --
what we did at the hurricane --
a concert for Hurricane Sandy,
which was all music --
Arcade Fire, The Who, Kanye --
-We went in between
Kanye West and Billy Joel.
-Yeah. So imagine
you've just seen --
You've just seen Kanye West.
You see them roll out
Billy Joel's piano.
Before that...
-But before that...
-...I walk out as me,
and he walks out as Drunk Uncle.
-Yeah, in costume,
which, by the way,
they made me wear to
Madison Square Garden.
I said, "Can I get dressed
when I get there?"
They said,
"There's nowhere to dress."
I said,
"Inside that tiny building?"
So, I showed up in costume
and sat in a room
with The Rolling Stones
in a wig.
-And I -- Well, 'cause
the thing Chris Rock said
that I remember is, he goes,
"You're going to go
do sketches?"
Because he knew.
-He said,
"Are you in a costume?"
I was like,
"I'm not that terrible, please."
And we went out there,
and the second we got there,
everyone got up to get a beer.
-Yeah. It was amazing,
because I do feel like
we were doing
Drunk Uncle for maybe
the biggest collection of
drunk uncles
that had ever been -- Yeah.
-It was -- Do you know
what happened after that?
-No, what happened after that?
-I...left.
-Okay. You just went home.
-I walked out and I didn't go
to the greenroom.
I walked through
Madison Square Garden.
I went down, like,
you know, the regular way,
through the be--
like, through the beginning.
You know, the opening.
The beginning of a building.
-Have you ever been to
the beginning of
Madison Square Garden?
-I got almost to the end.
And I walked out the front doors
of Madison Square Garden
and I walked home 13 blocks
dressed as Drunk Uncle.
-Yeah. The other thing --
-And they called me and they
said, "Your car is here."
And I said, "I'm home."
-I will say this, as well.
I feel like I've done
a lot of --
Like, comedy charity events
always is, like, a lower --
Like, it's going to go
worse than comedy
for people who pay to
see comedy -- always.
But when you walk off,
more often than not,
people are like,
"That was great."
Like, the people
backstage are like,
"We're here for a good cause."
Like, the sea parted
for you and I.
No one made eye contact.
It was just like...
-No handler came near me.
-No, nobody.
-I walked home alone.
-Yeah.
People, like, would see us,
and just, with their beers,
would be like, "Ooh."
-I believe --
It was Katie Holmes.
Katie Holmes went,
"I'm so sorry."
-The other thing is that,
afterwards,
do you remember,
this was a really cool thing.
Because all the money
was going to Hurricane Sandy,
but then they --
Half of it they gave to us
because of how -- They were
like, "We want to raise money."
They were like, "That was
a disaster, Hurricane Sandy,
but not..."
-This is a Hurricane Sandy suit.
-Oh, yeah.
They gave me this.
-Well, it was an honor --
It was an honor to
bomb with you that night.
-If you're gonna bomb with
Seth Meyers,
do it at Madison Square Garden.
-Yeah, that's it.
We played Madison Square --
We didn't do anything worse than
the Knicks do on almost...
Bobby Moynihan, everybody!
"Mr. Mayor" airs Tuesday
at 8:30 p.m. here on NBC.